las vegas raiders are getting ready for
their last exhibition game because after
sunday it is go time dancing chris
matthews joining us with more on the
battle by the bay hey thank you very
much brian yeah the niners hosting the
raiders is sunday one o'clock right here
on channel 8. this will be the first
time the two teams have played in a
preseason game since 2011 but the 40th
overall now san francisco has won three
in a row over the raiders head coach
john gruden met with the press for the
first time since saturday's win in la
and gave us an update on those two
worrisome injuries nick marl's foot and
here you see it javen white's knee and
it's not good news in fact it's very
concerning
looks like tomorrow will be out a little
bit longer than white
so
that's unfortunate but uh we'll have to
continue to develop our young
linebackers and perhaps find another are
we talking
regular season openers
50 at this point yeah i mean i'm not
going to announce any injuries until i
have to but
obviously we're concerned about them
being available
all right last saturday 10 amuse played
linebacker against the rams had three
tackles half a sack stop on special
teams don't forget sunday's game against
the niners will be right here on channel
8 your network home for the las vegas
raiders